foreign
[Music]
this particular project funded by the
National Library of Medicine is
producing a new National Data resource
for built environment characteristics
using Google sheet view images and
computer vision models and to estimate
the association between Bill environment
characteristics and health outcomes on a
national level
build environment in the simplest way is
just everything human built it includes
the streets all the buildings all the
houses we merged the Google image data
with the patient data so we looked at
coronary artery disease hypertension and
diabetes and then our mile control for
individual characteristics such as like
race ethnicity Insurance status English
language ability in our palette study we
merge those indicators with patient data
in Utah it was close to a million
patient records Healthcare Systems want
to know what are some exposures that
their patients encounter and what are
some of the predictors that can help
them better understand where's The
Chronic risk disease coming from we
found that like greeners of streets or
visible wires or the evaporated
buildings predicted prevalence of
coronary disease and hypertension
diabetes so crosswalk and sidewalks are
indicators of walkability so the more
walkable neighborhood is the more
encourages school activity we have other
indicators like Street trees and Street
Greenery which promote which we found
are associated with lower obesity and
better mental health we made a geoportal
where you can select the Navy feature
that you're interested in you can also
zoom into a location so you can type in
address or a city and it'll naturally
zoom in and and give you the
distribution of the characteristics at
that neighborhood people can interact
with the data it allows for a quick
analyzes flexible boundaries and
publicly available and it's a huge data
source for for the public health
researchers and policy makers doing this
way it can give us first to set a large
data to show us what is the impact of
the building we design and we build
without nlm support we wouldn't have the
protected time that we had over five
years we wouldn't be able to purchase
the images and also purchase the the
Computing software and Hardware to run
the models and also the granite help
support doctoral students and fund their
their entire studies it takes a typical
amount of time to walk in inventory
neighbor features of the built
environment
and so that would not be possible if you
are interested in any place across the
U.S and thus we need computer vision and
Google view images to enable the
analyzes at the national level
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]